so is everybody a Nazi now Plus is NP fo
really very dangerous or not and we will
talk about Steve ban and leaving the
White House I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show yeah its total eclipse
day and this is the day when a guy comes
back from the future and tells us all
about it and we give him all the power
just like in a Connecticut Yankee in
King Arthur's Court we'll talk a little
bit later about the solar eclipse if we
have to I'm still weirded out by the
fact that people are so obsessed with a
giant circle moving in front of another
giant circle in the sky but nonetheless
we will get to solar eclipses talk we're
actually filming this inside a
completely dark studio so I will be the
only one who can see after this is over
I'm very excited about this how the last
seeing person in America along with
Mathis and Jess the other people in this
room are safe so we will be your new
rulers when this is over and you're
blind wandering the streets not knowing
what is going on but we'll be able to
see cuz you're in here filming this so
ha before we get to any of the latest
news at first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at legacy box so when
was the last time you watched those home
movies that are stuck in your garage in
a box molds were and well wrapped to eat
them when was the last time you looked
at those pictures the answer is you
haven't in 30 years but they will be
ruined if you leave them out in the
garage and that's why you need to talk
to my friends over at legacy box you
take all the old pictures all of your
old film reels all of your old tapes VHS
tapes for the kids those are those tapes
used to put in the funny machine and you
take all of those and you send those all
the way to the legacy box they will send
you a box you put labels on them you
send it all the way back to legacy box
legacy box puts those all on a thumb
drive or DVD for you so you can access
them at any time instead of if there's a
fire or a flood or zombie apocalypse
during the Eclipse if any of that were
to happen you would no longer have to
worry about schlepping boxes of crap out
of your garage now you just grab the DVD
or the thumb drive and all your family
memories are preserved you load the
legacy box with your old tapes films
pictures and audio recordings you send
it back and they take care of everything
and the provide updates at every step
because they have those little barcodes
on them so you can actually see what
they've done with each particular piece
of material that you've sent back to
them over a quarter million families
have used legacy box for a limited time
go to legacy box comm slash Ben and you
get a 40% discount on your order that's
legacy box comm slash Ben you get a 40%
discount on your order it's a service we
definitely need to use it's great
or for your parents it is fantastic for
siblings as well makes a terrific
birthday gift
legacy voxcom slash bond that is legacy
voxcom slash man you have a 40% discount
on your order and that lets them know
that we sent you so there's this very
irritating line of thought that is now
appeared from the left and it is super
duper irritating and is that if you
condemn auntie feh and you also condemn
neo-nazis you are there for covering for
neo-nazis this is stupid and it's part
of a broader effort by the left to pain
to everyone in the world who is on the
right as a neo-nazi or Nazi sympathizer
or Confederate sympathizer it's really
ugly as I said last week there's a
number of propositions I think that 95
percent of Americans agree on Nazis bad
communism bad violence against peaceful
protesters bad right those three seems
to be pretty simple and it seems to me
like the vast majority of Americans
should agree with those but because of
political motivations on all political
sides all of this has gone into the
background it's receded into the
background instead we're clubbing each
other over the head apparently all right
winners are supposed to be neo-nazis and
all left wingers are antiva and narrate
the to show me so today I want to talk
about who is who because I think there's
a lot of category or going on I think
that people are looking at the rally
that happened in Boston the Boston Free
Speech Coalition rally and the left is
saying that's a bunch of neo-nazis and
then the right is looking at all the
protesters the 40,000 protesters who
showed up and they're saying all of
those people are anti feh no no okay so
if you're going to gauge the particular
merit of a group you have to gauge them
along two lines one line is what do they
believe and the other line is what do
they do right you can gauge the morality
of what somebody believes and engage the
morality of what they do so one of the
things that's been very irritating is
when people like me say an Tifa is an
evil group because they violate the
social contract by beating up people
with whom they disagree people say oh
you're saying they're worse than the
Nazis no I'm not saying that worse than
the Nazis in terms of their belief
system I'm saying if they initiate
violence and the Nazis don't then they
are worse than the Nazis in terms of
their particular behavior now the Nazis
initiate violence then we have moral
equivalence in terms of their behavior
and the Nazis are worse on ideology
I'm trying to be very specific in
particular here because I don't like
broad labels now I want to correct
myself on that score because I've said
before that the left has been very kind
to antifa let me be clear about this I
mean everyone on the Left I mean many
mainstream leftists many more mainstream
leftist are kinder to Antipa than
mainstream right-wingers are kind to the
alt-right
okay the alt-right has been a movement
that a lot of people on the right have
kind of went in not at present in Trump
and Steve Bannon among them but the idea
that the entire right has been winking
and nodding or or openly celebrating
free winking and nodding openly
celebrating me all right that's not true
and the left many mainstream leftists
have been openly celebrating Antigua so
I think a great case in point is what
happened over the weekend in Boston so
in Boston this weekend there is what the
Boston free speech coalition called it's
free speech rally leading up to it the
mayor of Boston and him Thomas Walsh he
said that he doesn't want any of the
white supremacists in his city here's
what he had to say we also have a
message to the hate groups especially
any that are planned to come to our city
this weekend Boston does not welcome you
here Boston does not want you here
Boston rejects your message we reject
racism we reject white supremacy we
reject anti-semitism we reject the KKK
we reject neo-nazis we reject the metric
terrorism and we reject hatred and we
will do every single thing in our power
to keep hate out of our city okay so
it's fine for him to say that he wants
to prevent that people who are hateful
shouldn't be in the city that's fine
when he says we'll do all in our power
to keep them from entering the city
that's illegal okay you can't prevent
people from moving into your city
because of their viewpoint that's just
not something that you can do but what's
amazing about this is is who are the
Boston Free Speech Coalition so let's
talk about this for a second because
here's my fear my fear is that what
happened in Charlottesville is now going
to be conflated with events that are not
alright events that are not white
supremacist so I'm going to speak in
Berkeley in September 14th is media
going to cover that as though I'm an alt
writer because they're convenient
narrative I'm some sort of neo-nazi
because I'll be absurd I was the number
one target of the alt-right in 2016
right where yarmulke I'm an Orthodox Jew
because it would be insane but I fear
that the media and the left are going to
do exactly that if you're the media
unless you're going to do exactly that
and they're going to use the Boston
situation as sort of their prototype for
this so Boston Free Speech Coalition it
originally invited a couple of guys who
are what they call out light one is
named Joe Biggs and the other is bass
stick man we've had basic men on the
program before specifically to talk
about and chief of violence in
Sacramento and Berkeley right so there
these are guys who are friendly with the
alt-right but I don't think it's fair
necessarily to call them devotees of
all right per se in any case these guys
are both slated to speak at this
particular rally and they're both
cancelled because the rally said Wilson
we don't want to be associated with
anybody who's even alt light we don't
want people who are associated with that
so we openly condemn white supremacist
and neo Nazism and they all try this is
what the organizers of the event said
they said this clearly and openly in the
days leading up to this event and they
said we don't want anything to do with
those people and in fact here's a
picture from the event okay at the event
there was a guy who's a congressional
candidate whose name is dr. Shiva
ayyadurai who's a congressional
candidate in Boston here's a picture
from this event and what you can see is
that they're standing inside a gazebo on
Boston Common I know they conceived oh
well because I used to go to school in
Boston so I know Boston Commons pretty
well and his suite says to all fake news
this was the white supremacist free
speech rally I just spoke at okay what
you can see is it says Shiva for
Senator Shiva for Senate and then people
are holding up signs that say black
lives do matter okay does that sound
like a white supremacist rally to you
they're hoping up signs that take black
lives do matter at this supposed white
supremacist rally and then there's
another kind of lefty thing says no to
GMOs stop nonsense though it's not a
lefty think the black lives matter it by
the way it's sort of a lefty thing to
pander to the black lives matter
movement but matter movement but there's
a person who's holding up a sign it's
also sponsored by Shiva for Senate and
it says clean food clean air clean
government no to GMOs stop Monsanto
against a real lefty cause the anti GMO
cause does this sound like a white
supremacist rally to you so on Twitter I
went out and I said you know what the
evidence that this was actually a white
supremacist rally because it was sort of
being pitched that way even Huffington
Post said it's not a white supremacist
rally even Huffington Post said the
white supremacist didn't show up but the
but was this alleged so the only
evidence that anybody could see there's
one guy literally one guy who showed up
wearing a shirt with the so-called 14
words the 14 words are the sentence that
neo-nazis say something about we have to
protect white civilization for our
progeny it's a few more words than that
is 14 but that's why there's this
neo-nazi symbol in 1488 it's the 14 word
slogan about protecting light
civilization for our children and then
eight-eight is Heil Hitler
right because H is the 8th letter in the
alphabet there's one guy who is wearing
the 14 words on the back of his shirt
that was legitimately the only evidence
that I could see that this was an all
right rally as
realized the media covered this as
though the neo-nazis had shown up in
Boston and they were shut down by 40,000
demonstrators okay this is the problem
when you start conflating people who are
normal conservatives normal right-wing
normal Republicans with the neo-nazis
you're going to get a backlash and it's
really gross CNN has been doing this -
CNN published an entire list of supposed
hate groups and they got the list
directly from the Southern Poverty Law
Center the Southern Poverty Law Center
is a radical left group that routinely
labeled normal conservatives as
neo-nazis and hate groups so for example
they label the David Horowitz Freedom
Center where I used to work they'll
about a hate group okay they've they've
labeled a bunch of other a bunch of
other groups like the Family Research
Council right they labeled that a hate
group that labeling let a nutcase named
Floyd Lee Corkins to go over to the
Family Research Council in 2012 and he
tried to shoot people at that particular
establishment CNN ran a story all about
how the SPL sees labels of hate groups
meant that that these were all hate
groups that were in league with the
worst in America a City Journal writes a
mark Pulliam writes the SPLC has an
undeniable ideological agenda in
addition to attend dentists list of
seven 917 hate groups it also maintains
a list of more than 1,600 purported
extremists or extremist groups including
charles murray and one time they labeled
ben Carson an extremist because he was
opposed to gay marriage yet CNN was
pushing this out there as though in the
aftermath of the neo-nazi rally in
Charlottesville this was the real threat
was all of these groups were basically
neo-nazis you wonder why the right react
so negatively to the left take on all of
this
you wonder why maybe it's because the
left instead of unifying with the ninety
five percent of Americans I talked about
at the beginning instead of doing that
they're much more focused on trying to
broaden out mainstream members of the
left more interested in broadening out
their critique of neo-nazis to fit the
entire right-wing movement to fit all
concerned all conservatives the
neo-nazis aren't even conservative okay
they're leftist in the sense that they
believe in bigger governments they
believe in government intervention they
don't within the Constitution of the
United States they believe in government
involvement in things like health care
and they're only right-wing compared to
left wingers okay in sort of the
European sense in the same with the Nazi
Party in Nazi Germany was right-wing
compared to the Communist Party in Nazi
Germany but had nothing to do with
American conservatism not season has
nothing to do with American conservatism
the left is very much invested in trying
to tie those two together and then
what's the purpose of that well number
one they think it gains some points
politically by calling everybody on the
right of deplorable they think that this
is somehow going to win them elections
and then they do something else and this
is even worse this is they start to make
excuses and room for folks at antiva and
if I have to gauge the threat to America
between the neo-nazi movement and Antipa
I would suggest right now that the
threat from an Tifa to the American
social fabric is just as or more
dangerous than the threat from the
neo-nazis not because their ideology is
worse than your Nazi ideology as of
course worse but because the mainstream
right is not embracing the neo-nazis
many members of the mainstream Left are
embracing Antipa and Antipa is based on
the proposition that rejects the basic
Max Weber Max Weber concept which is
that in a civilized society the monopoly
on use of force has to belong to the
government right civilization is based
on the idea that we all got together
when banded together and we said to the
government you protect our right you
have the gun
we're not going to shoot each other in
the streets you have the gun we have
police forces and we have army and and
people rejects all that they say listen
it's up to us we're going to go out in
the street and we're going to kill
people and we're going to harm people
and we're going to hurt people and burn
things and loot property and all the
rest of it that's dangerous attitude is
here I'm going to talk about what Antipa
did at this Boston rally which I think
is a much bigger story then 10 people
showing up for a free speech rally and
being labeled white supremacist but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Birch gold so if you're
looking the world's right now and it
feels chaotic it feels out of control
I I certainly am if you feel like the
stock market is doing well but there's
still some volatility to come in the
stock market you should have some of
your portfolio at the very least in
precious metals the people who can help
you do that are the folks over at Birch
gold Birch gold has a worm standing
track record of continued success a
five-star a nay plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau countless
five-star reviews right now if you go to
birchgold.com slash spending get a
comprehensive 16 page free kit revealing
how gold and silver can protect your
savings and how you can legally move
your IRA or 401k out of stocks and bonds
and into a precious metals IRA without
engaging tax
to quences so go over to birchgold.com
and slash men that is birchgold.com
slash men make sure you use the slash
bends they know that we sent you if
you're looking to invest in precious
metals the folks I trust with that are
over at birchgold.com slash been okay so
as I say the media covered this great
triumph of the left in Boston all these
white supremacists who weren't really
white supremacists except for apparently
one guy they say a forty thousand
protesters showed up and it was just a
grand and glorious thing first of all
forty thousand people protesting neo
Nazism is a grand and glorious thing
that's fine that's great but to pretend
that Antipas did not play a role in
Boston is to be silly now I do want to
make a slight distinction here and I
think it's important for Charlottesville
and understanding it the President Trump
said there were good there were good
people on both sides in Charlottesville
and in the protest crowd again I'm still
waiting to see all the good people in
Charlottesville in the torchlight March
haven't seen him but when he says there
was violence on both sides that's
definitely true now we do have to look
at the proportion so if you're looking
at the proportion of violent people in
Charlottesville on the neo-nazi side
versus you're looking at the proportion
of violent people in Charlottesville on
the Antipa side okay that as a
percentage of the larger group from what
I can tell and maybe I'm wrong about
this but the information that I can see
it looks like a larger group of the
neo-nazis as a proportion were we're
ready to go than a proportion of the
protesters and people was there but it's
not a huge group in Boston I guess there
were 33 arrests out of 40,000 people
that doesn't sound like many until you
realize that when you go to a Dodger
game there are 40,000 people there and
there are zero arrests 33 arrests is
actually rather sizable contingents of
people getting arrested and even the
Boston PD it's amazing that the duality
that the the Boston police will engage
in they'll say that everybody was
peaceful everybody was great and they'll
say this there was a lot of talk in the
week leading up about bottles being
flown with urine at our offices and I
wanted to make sure that they you know
that you had to have a good arm to
basically Explo and get at them so you
know we basically wanted them separated
and I'm sorry to report we did have some
bottles thrown at our officers that
didn't have urine in it a couple of our
officers were hit with that they were
hit with a lot of stuff today
and I'm very proud of the job they did
and it goes to the professionalism of
this department okay so he says that it
was basically a peaceful protest many
fist people were flinging bottles of pee
at the cops and there's tape of all this
stuff here's some tape of a woman with
an American flag being dragged at Boston
rally presumably by members of Antigua
you can tell the antifa folks because
they cover their faces because they're
committing criminal acts oh if the
viewers watching right now take a look
at what happens to this woman who is
holding an American flag
she's holding an American flag and a
protester come to her dragged her along
there pulls her anyway
there it was lift Loftus you can see her
flag blowing up on the ground
hey just delightful people and that that
wasn't the only situation some
pro-lifers were apparently attacked
there was a journalist who tweeted this
out these protests rarely and pretty
Antipa folks just mobbed some
anti-abortion protesters with posters
yelled into our posters till the cops
came and then the Antipa went after the
police officer so here's some footage of
the auntie for people going at the
police officers okay no this is not the
white supremacist this was a bunch of
the mp4 people and some of the other
protesters presumably are nope they're
all and FIFA or which other groups they
are with but you can see there's a
violent at this particular event is not
coming from the all right and the white
supremacist who apparently again we're
explicitly denounced by the organizers
of the rally it was coming from the left
or some more footage a man Tifa going
after the cops
[Applause]
where to go
got black thread on you cursing in the
cop you got black bleep on you something
like that and then you have a trump
supporter wearing an Israeli flag told
you get the eff out of Boston is just
delightful folks have your name donated
you everything you stand against
everyone violence
no violence
Ruby I want to show that people
shouldn't be afraid to voice thread you
and your lawyers in chambers I be afraid
to go outside a circuit riveted it's
pretty fun and he's right it is pretty
sad that things like that happened and
it wasn't relegated just to Boston there
was an anti supposedly anti white
supremacist protest led by leftist
groups in Dallas and here they are
shouting about the cops and how the cops
are the Klan
[Applause]
you can hear them shouting cops and
clams I'll hand in hand you can see that
some of these people again are the
Antipa folks they've got the masks
across their face now why is all this
important okay why am i showing off this
footage of violent and nasty horrible
and Tifa people the reason is because
unlike the right which has universally
condemned the neo-nazis in the all right
and and is trying to disassociate from
these people their mainstream leftists
who are embracing all of this stuff and
they are using this binary logic again
the neo-nazis are bad so and Tifa must
be okay this is dangerous
okay this is really dangerous I'm not
talking about just dangerous in terms of
people cursing at each other yelling at
each other we've been having that for a
couple hundred years I'm talking about
dangerous in violent terms dangerous in
serious violent terms and I want to talk
about that in just a second but first I
need to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Lending Tree so right now you're
looking for a mortgage you're looking to
buy a house and so what do you do you go
and you ask your friend where'd you get
your mortgage they refer you to somebody
and you work with that person but you
don't know if you're getting the lowest
rate or the best rate you don't know if
you're getting the best service that's
where Lending Tree comes in the average
Lending Tree customer can save twenty
thousand dollars over the life of their
loan that is average okay which means
that most of the huge percentage of
their customers can save even more
whether you're looking for a new
mortgage refire home equity loan Lending
Tree is the only place where you get up
to five real offers from American top
lenders and you can compare them
side-by-side for free it takes like
three minutes I've actually gone through
the website just to check it out it
takes no time at all to get a bunch of
comparison offers from Lending free.com
find out how much you can save today at
Lending Tree comm slash Ben that's
Lending Tree comm slash Ben don't be
ripped off again people work with
mortgage brokers they don't know who
they are and then they're surprised when
the charges are high they don't maybe
they have researched it they talked to
their friends it turns out they got a
really high rate well there's no need
for that go over to Lending Tree comm
slash Ben and get all of the best prices
compared so you can get the best deal
again that's Lending Tree comm slash Ben
and use the slash bonds they know that
we sent you okay so as I say I don't
want to talk anymore about these fringe
movements the neo-nazis and Antipa they
are fringe movements I want to talk
instead about whether they are being
mainstreamed on the right is it being
mainstreamed are the neo-nazis being
mainstream this was the great fear of
what President Trump did last week when
he seemed to legitimize the alt-right
when he seems to see
there are good people in the crowd with
the alright when you seem to make a
moral equivalence between the protesters
and some of the protesters who are
protesting with the alt-right and the
neo-nazis right now that seems to be the
problem people were afraid that this is
going to be mainstreamed and the
universal condemnation was strong and
lasting and loud there are openly
leftist who are saying today and have
been saying now for a week
that Antigua is not a problem and
remember this is not just them embracing
an tifa's viewpoint this is them
embracing an tifa's central contention
which is that violence in streets is
sometimes necessary here's that same
Dartmouth professor we were talking
about last week who wrote an op-ed for
The Washington Post
talking about how and Tifa is
necessaries Marc Braves lecturer at
Dartmouth College I think that a lot of
people recognize that when pushed
self-defense is a legitimate response to
white supremacist and neo-nazi violence
and you know we've tried ignoring
neo-nazis in the past we've seen how
that turned out in the 20s and 30s a nun
lesson of history is you need to take it
with the utmost seriousness before it's
too late we've seen the millions of
deaths that have come from not taking it
seriously enough and we can see that
really the way that white supremacy
grows the way that neo Nazism grows is
by becoming legitimate becoming
established becoming everyday family
friendly wear khakis instead of hoods
and the way to stop that is what people
did in Boston what people did in
Charlottesville pull the emergency brake
and say you can't make this normal
there's a big difference between
confronting fascism and confronting
other forms of violence so we can see
that during the 30s and 40s there was no
public opinion to be leveraged by
nonviolent resistance if you get fascist
to be powerful enough in government
they're simply not going to listen to
the kind of public opinion that
non-violence can generate that's the
argument they're not going with other
than idea the white supremacists are
powerful and government still powerful
that we have to go out on the streets
that our guns
listen I've said for a long time that if
government becomes tyrannical then we
ought to have guns in order to protect
ourselves but you're not talking about a
government that's enforcing neo-nazi
views a CNN made the same mistake
there's a headline that CNN actually ran
yesterday the original headline and then
they and then they changed it because
they got backlash from Antipa it said
unmasking the leftist Antipa movement
activists seek peace through violence
which is accurate right it demonstrates
the irony of the mt4 movement so what do
they do they updated the piece and they
got rid of the last half of the
activists seek peace through violence
they got rid of that because they
wouldn't want to offend Antipa okay
representative Steve Cohen who is it was
a democratic representative I believe he
is from he from Tennessee yeah he's from
Tennessee and here he was defending
Antipa well it was equivocated because
it's tried to put blame on both sides
there's even if the anta file was there
and did things it doesn't they were
there because of the Nazis and because
of the Confederates and when they went
out marched the night before with those
tiki torches it was a reminder of
Kristallnacht in my mind the 1938 German
terrorism on Jewish people in Berlin and
it was also looked like Klan rallies
where they've used to have big bonfires
and then that burn crosses and so that
the whole idea of the fire I mean it was
it was so well staged to remind people
of that and yelling the Jews will not
take our place blood and soil these were
just just the most bone-chilling Martin
sounds and chants and they were in
lockstep okay and that's true but so
what in terms of the violence why is
that justify violence again as somebody
who is an Orthodox Jew I have no
fondness or not these are Klansmen I've
spent my entire career fighting Nazis
and Klansmen David Duke came after me
personally last year on Twitter okay I'm
very much in favor of these movements
disappearing immediately they're
disgusting they're evil they are
horrifying God should spit on them
they're they're awful in every way
that's said in a civilized society you
don't get to justify an Tifa just
because you don't like stuff that people
are saying and this is dangerous stuff
the reason it's dangerous stuff is
because people who are I've said before
I'm only going to attribute violence to
rhetoric when the rhetoric explicitly
calls for violence and PIPA explicitly
calls for violence what the left is
doing that people like Steve Cohen what
mainstream leftists are doing many of
them is they are now explicitly
pooh-poohing violence when you
explicitly puh-puh-puh violence you are
going to make it more common and I want
to read you a little bit of a guy named
Everett Glenn Miller you probably missed
this story Everett Glenn Miller when his
according to heavy calm is a former
marine with mental health history and he
was named as the suspect accused of
shooting and killing two Kissimmee
Florida police officers a guy named
Matthew Baxter and charged
richard sam howard the police chief says
was in ambush miller was a miller went
by the name on facebook malik muhammad
ali he only changed that recently and
right before he went on the shooting
spree killing two cops he shared a
picture of martin luther king jr. that
said for this from august 18th it said
when I said March I didn't mean for ever
mother effers shoot back I'll even wrote
with the photo when them n words wake up
it's going to be some held to answer for
you only can poke at I up dog for so
long
once that chain breaks it's over wake up
America before it's too late and then
another post said said racist ass
America America is evil and then there
were derogatory post about Trump post
about the Confederate monument issue and
Nazis in Charlottesville Virginia on
August 15th
they shared a page a video of the
Charlottesville clashes and wrote
Confederate Nazis I will hurt you all
you are the enemy you can run but you
can't hide so if you have a group of
people this is what an Tifa does who
equate the police with the bad guys who
equate conservatives with the bad guys
and who openly say that violence is
necessary in order to stop the bad guys
when you have mainstream people on the
left like Steve Cohen when your
mainstream people on the Left like
Michael Eric Dyson when your mainstream
people on the Left like Mark Bray at the
Washington Post when you have those
people making excuses for the violence
you think the violence is going to
become more common or less common do you
think that it's going to get worse or
better do you really have so little
belief in the police that you don't
think that the police can stop the Nazis
though attend Nazis do you really
believe that the police are in league
with them so I'm calling on you UPS I
called on President Trump I called on
the right to disown the alt-right I've
been doing it for over a year well over
a year and now with equal or more fervor
I call on people on the left
you must disown auntie feh you must
disown the violence that is being done
in your name and he was doing it in your
name and Democrats aren't disowning it
Democrats aren't Fitz owning it instead
they're focusing in unconservative on
Confederate rather Confederate monuments
instead of focusing on Confederate
monuments and those are the real threats
appease no there's a group in America
right now that is openly calling for
violence and property destruction and
it's being and it's being shied away
from by members of the mainstream left
and that is really gross I've seen some
members of the left who are willing to
disown this stuff I've seen some
I've seen some people who are willing to
say that MTF is a problem but here's
what I'm afraid of I'm afraid that I'm
going to go to Berkeley on September
14th and then tief is going to show up
and they're going to get violent in the
media because they want their narrative
or violence against right wingers is
justified that the media is going to
proclaim that it's my fault that Antipa
showed up and got violent that's what
I'm concerned about I'm concerned
somebody's going to get killed I'm
concerned some of my security guards you
can get hurt and I'm concerned emedia is
going to blame my views for that even
though I've been anti anti anti outright
overtly so for a long time which is why
when I speak at Berkeley the topic that
I'm going to speaking on that I'm going
to be speaking on is why all of the
following groups are destroying America
and Tifa the alt-right BLM social
justice warriors radical feminists I'm
going to talk about all of these groups
and why they're destroying America's
social fabric I'm going to talk about
all of that and we'll see if the media
are honest enough to recognize that I'm
condemning all the group's they say
ought to be condemned like the alt-right
and have been doing so for a year or
whether they lie and they say that just
because I think that BLM is a bad group
that espouses bad things that I am
therefore a rightful victim of an Tifa
because I think that will expose the
media's agenda I think that if the media
decide that they are going to target the
stuff that I say just like the stuff
that you say you're a normal
conservative they're going to target you
as an athlete they decided target Mia to
Nazi I think it'll say a whole hell of a
lot considering the fact that there's
been no one who's been more anti
outright more anti white supremacist
than I have been certainly over the past
year by statistics and the but I fear
that the left is going to lie about it
nonetheless okay I want to talk about
the Confederate monuments statue MST ban
and leaving the White House but for that
you're going to have to go over to daily
wired.com right now become a subscriber
for just $9.99 a month you too can
subscribe to daily wire you get the rest
of this show live it is a video show so
if you're just listening you go over to
daily wire you can see this in all of
its glory our beautiful studios you can
see all of the clips that we show you
can be part of the mailbag which we do
live on Fridays and you can also watch
Andrew Klavan show which is going to be
on at 10:30 today you can watch Michael
Knowles's show which is going to be on
at 12:30 today you can watch all of
those lives in part of their mail bags
as well if you want the annual
subscription then you get not 499
dollars a year you get that the most
magnificent of all leftist ears hot or
cold tumblers
it is apparently made of dragonglass so
if you should ever experience the horror
of being on a frozen lake in the middle
of nowhere and White Walkers are coming
at you and you don't know how to put
them down then this particular tumblr
should do the trick leftist cures hot or
cold you will want this to pass on to
your children and grandchildren just as
the Valyrian sword was passed on to
Samwell Tarly in any case you will
definitely want this so $99 gets you all
of those things plus the website ad free
and my podcast ad free by the way that
means the even when it's reposted later
we cut the ads out so you can just watch
it straight through or if you just want
to go to iTunes or SoundCloud listen
later please subscribe at iTunes please
leave us a review we always appreciate
it it helps with the rankings and we
will we'll see on the other side and
yeah that's see you in a second
[Music]
you
all righty and we're back so that was a
stellar pitch let's say let's move on to
what Democrats are really focused on are
they focused on condemning antifa
the right has been spending weeks
talking about how white supremacy is
evil Paul Ryan released a statement this
morning talking about how white
supremacy is evil I don't know a lot of
right-wingers we're not saying this
other than pap you can and Democrats
however are focusing in on the real
issue and this is such a mistake for
them you know president Trump
successfully pivoted from the alt-right
issue that was that was kind of the
thorn in his side he pivoted instead the
Confederate statues talking about
whether Confederate monuments should go
down and because the left is so radical
they immediately left on this and
decided to make this the issue now
that's very stupid politics the polls
showed the vast majority of Americans
want to keep the Confederate statues or
at the very least don't care very much
okay but they've decided to make this
their key issue and this demonstrates I
think the disconnect between a lot of
people who are living in Washington DC
and New York in LA and Chicago and a lot
of the people who are living in the rest
of the country who frankly don't care
very much about these Confederate
memorials and don't think that they're
the worst thing in the world or the
cause of a lot of violence yeah you're
seeing Democrats push this stuff very
hard the same way the Democrats pushed
really hard on the Washington Redskins
issue have to rename the team very
importantly rename the team they're
doing the same thing with Confederate
monuments now I think there's a stronger
case to rename it get rid of Confederate
monuments by far than getting rid of the
name of the Washington Redskins but the
left is treating this as though this is
the real threat of violence
so antifa isn't the real threat of
violence no Confederate statues are the
real threat of violence jeh Johnson who
is the Secretary of Homeland Security
under President Obama here's what he had
to say about removing these statues what
alarms so many of us from a security
perspective is that so many of the
statues the Confederate monuments are
now modern day becoming symbols and
rallying points for white nationalism
for neo-nazis for the KKK and this is
most alarming we fought a world war
against Nazism the KKK rained terror on
African Americans for generations and so
a number of Americans rightly Republican
and Democrat are very concerned and very
alarmed and I say
those in cities and states were taking
down a lot of these monuments for
reasons of public safety and security
okay so here's my question who is the
Secretary of Homeland Security for the
last four years of the Obama
administration why didn't he take DNA in
the moment
yeah all right was doing this before why
didn't he take down any of those
monuments and the answer is because it's
the left seeking to lump in men main
members the mainstream left seeking to
lump in support for Confederate
monuments with all right ISM and white
supremacy again I think there's a very
strong case that some of these things
should come down I don't know why
there's Jefferson Davis highways in
Arizona actually I do know a lot of
these monuments were erected in the
middle of the civil rights movement as
sort of a backlash against the civil
rights movement which really is gross I
mean if you erect a Confederate Memorial
in the middle of the civil rights
movement because you're attempting to
say something about civil rights then
that's pretty disgusting some of these
monuments went up in like 1960 because
they're not 100 years old they're not
part of the historic South or anything
they're going up in states like Arizona
that wasn't even existence at the time
of the Civil War so I think that that's
a problem
that said this idea that these are
flashpoints that this is high priority
for the United States it's sort of like
the argument after the evil Dylann storm
roof shot up a black church that the key
issue was whether people should fly a
Confederate flag on their truck and the
answer was this was not a major issue
five minutes ago why is it a major issue
now if it is a major issue then we
should have this discussion outside the
context of a radical shooting someone
here's the problem when you use radicals
who shoot people as an excuse to have
broader conversations then you end up
dismissing entirely benign people you
end up hurting entirely benign people in
the process so I'll give you an example
for the leftists in the audience okay
for people who are on the left in the
audience liberals in the audience after
the shooting the Congressional baseball
shooting there are people like me who I
think we're intellectually honest enough
to say I'm not blaming Bernie Sanders
for this right his rhetoric is not
something that I want to blame for a guy
going and shooting Congress people we've
always had rhetoric that's been very
heated in American politics I disagree
with everything Bernie Sanders has to
say I think that no one should ever give
him a pooping cup I don't think it's
important but to say that we're going to
have a now referendum on Bernie Sanders
is language because in that case went
out and shot some people if we are going
to judge the veracity of an ideology or
the morality of a rhetoric by the people
who are outside the realm of the normal
then we're going to basically have to
all shut up because there are a lot of
crazy people out there who are set off
by a lot of crazy things and so this is
my problem with having missus convert in
this conversation in a broader context
by suggesting with charlottesville is
some sort of representation of the vast
majority of people who want to stop the
Confederate statues from going down this
is why Trump was smart to pivot to the
Confederate statue issue because the
vast majority of people who are
protesting on that Friday night a couple
of weeks ago in Charlottesville Ford the
robert e lee's statue were neo-nazis
Klansmen all writers the vast majority
of people across the country who don't
want robert e lee statutes to come down
or none of those things and there i
think trump is correct and is smart to
to pivot and i think the left is idiotic
to follow him in that pivot they're not
going to do themselves any political
favors it's amazing as low as chrome
sinks in the polls everybody keeps
saying all trumps failing in the polls
he's following apart if trumps falling
apart then why is it that he had like 39
percent approval rating in wisconsin and
one in the state anyway there's still a
Democrat who's going to have to run
against him and the reason Democrats are
having trouble is because they're
recruiting radicals who run in their
party people like Kamala Harris if they
ran Joe Biden somebody who is relatively
radical on politics but it's perceived
as moderate he would want president
Trump but instead they're looking to the
left wing of their party they're looking
to people who pander and that's not
going to do them any service okay
so in other news Steve Danon is out at
the White House this broke in the middle
of the show on Friday and I've had a
chance to sort of collect my thoughts on
what this means I don't think it means a
whole helluva lot I think the Bandon had
already been marginalized at the White
House he had very little input at the
White House already him going back to
Breitbart doesn't make very much of a
difference
Alice Marlow who's the editor in chief
over there I got to say Alex is probably
miserable this morning because Steve is
not the easiest person to work with but
that said Steve heading back to
Breitbart isn't markedly going to change
things other than it's sort of a green
light to Breitbart to start attacking
all the people who surround Trump that's
going to be the move at Breitbart
they're going to move to attack Gary
Cohn they're going to move to attack
Jovanka right Jared and Ivanka Kushner
they're going to they're going to attack
HR McMaster which they've been doing
with alacrity for some time now and
she's going to become louder and more
strident Bannen is going to insist of
course
he's trying to help Trump but Bannon
Vanden cares about man man doesn't care
about the future Breitbart he doesn't
care about their traffic the only thing
that Bannon cares about really is being
perceived as a big man on campus and
that means that he has to present
himself as a sort of populist hero in
fact after he left on Friday he
headlined right Bandhan did an editorial
meeting and the first headline that went
up was this in giant orange letters
Steven K Bannon returns home to
Breitbart news and then in quotes
populist hero I mean nothing like
fulfilling the mooches expectations of
you there for going back and immediately
running a headline about how wonderful
you are but what that means is that
Bannon is going to sort of present
himself as the voice of morality from
the populist right that can be a thorn
for Trump a little bit as it can be a
major thorn I don't think so I think
Bannon knows better than to alienate a
lot of the Trump centric voters but if
Trump ever becomes so vulnerable that
Breitbart can make a difference then you
can see Bannon in a revenge move sort of
moving to hurt him do I think it makes a
huge difference inside the
administration no it's just another
indicator that this administration was
never conservative okay for as much like
this like CBN and personally Steve
Bannon is right-wing on immigration
Steve Annan is right-wing on Israel
Steve Bannon is right-wing on national
security so all of those things have
sort of been moved off of the off of the
spectrum a little bit ban was more
isolationist than right-wing I should
sin on national security but he was very
much in favor of a military buildup a
lot of that has now been moved off to
the side Trump administration for all
the people who thought he was going to
be the great conservative Halcyon let me
just point out the people now
surrounding him are entirely Democrats
or generals there is not a single major
registered Republican who surrounds the
President of the United States in his
inner circle HR McMaster is a general
john kelly is a general Chardon Ivanka
were registered Democrats until five
minutes ago Gary Cohen was a registered
Democrat minuchin was a registered
Democrat all of the people who surround
him all the people who are closest to
him are either generals or registered
Democrats okay that is not going to bode
well for Trump the only thing that might
save the the conservative agenda truly
is that number one there's there's a
Republican Congress and number two
Democrats will not work with Trump
they hate Trump so much that they're
willing to to to cut off their nose in
spite of their face the fact is that if
Democrats were smart what they would
immediately do is begin going to
an interim tank let's get some of your
legislation done and they start pushing
for a single-payer health care and get
Trump to sign it they start pushing for
infrastructure bills and they get Trump
to sign it they start pushing for tax
hikes and get Trump to sign it I'm Trump
more than willing to go to war with
McConnell and Ryan he's already shown
that he's willing to do that so how far
to left his Trump move is not dictated
right now by the Republican Party it's
dictated by a democratic party that
doesn't want to work with Trump which is
quite fascinating okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like so
unfortunately Jerry Lewis died over the
weekend he was 94 years old growing up
we we liked Jerry Lewis movies we're not
French but we liked to Jerry Lewis
movies nonetheless one of my favorite
Jerry Lewis films is a very underrated
film called cinderfella and it's a
reverse of the Cinderella story except
he is Cinderella right he's a guy and he
falls in love with the princess and if
visited Jerry Lewis was a great physical
comedian this is one of the scenes from
cinderfella where he's sitting in the
kitchen his pair of his the stepmother
has made him basically the maid and he's
sitting in the kitchen after serving
them dinner listening to the radio and
this is sort of classic Jerry Lewis all
right things about this movie is the
Count Basie music
[Music]
very kid-friendly particularly and
there's a lot of no showing my daughter
who's three-and-a-half a clip from this
movie there's a scene where he does a
dance with with the princess and Count
Basie's band is there this is part of
his transformation is that Count Basie
Dan shows up as part of his
transformation into into the prince and
it's it's a little bit slow but there
are a couple of scenes in it that are
really really funny so cinderfella
highly recommend it
okay other things that I like this catch
in the Junior Little League World Series
is just incredible and this is one of
the best catches I've ever seen in any
league period watch the centerfielder go
back on this ball it's amazing
go on a wild pitch is just a really
quick way to go home
raggedy trip it back he's at the warning
track look at Junior League please no no
I thought so I the transition between a
happy high and the liquid but wow great
catch kid I know who you are but that's
a fantastic catch so anytime there's a
good piece of baseball put it on the
show okay time for some things that I
hate
so just to show you how evil a lot of
the neo-nazis are and the and the white
supremacists are and some of the alright
members are the Charlottesville rally
organizer actually tweeted this out yes
it's Jason Kessler the piece of garbage
who was punched in the face at the
rallies that Heather hire was a fat
disgusting communist communist until 94
million looks like it was payback time
and then he links directly to you guess
if the daily stormer the neo-nazi site
yeah again not a lot of very fine people
doing this not a lot of very kind people
involved with that particular rally
horrifying horrifying in every sense of
the word okay other things that I hate
Jerry Falwell Jr who was on TV and Jerry
Falwell Jr has been the loudest
evangelical advocate for president Trump
he is of course the Dean of Liberty
University I know we have a lot of
listeners over Liberty to want to say hi
to all of the all the folks who listen
over at Liberty University I'm sorry
that the Jerry Falwell Jr said something
that's dumb over the weekend here is
Jerry Falwell Jr on ABC's this week
talking about President Trump's response
to Charlottesville the only groups he
identified by name as evil and causing
what happened in Charlottesville or the
Nazis the KKK and the white supremist
that's what I thought was bold well let
me tell you what he said though let's go
back to this he said there were very
fine people on both sides do you believe
they were very fun I have no idea he's
high he has inside information that I
don't have I don't know if there were
historical peers there who were trying
to preserve some statues I don't know
but but he had he had information I
didn't have and I believe that he was I
think he knew that something he saw
videos of who was there I think he was
talking about what he had seen
information that he had I don't have
okay okay this idea that he had
information that Jerry Paul Turner
didn't have and that's why he said what
he said I'm kind of sick of attributing
the president from the information that
is just not accurate hey I don't see if
that information is not there it's not
there
end of story so enough if you're gonna
defend President Trump depends on the
merits don't make up stuff like you some
omnipotent omniscient all-seeing God I
okay it's nonsense I still would like to
see the evidence of the great people
that were there on that Friday night
that President Trump was apparently
talking about because I don't actually
see that evidence okay so we'll be back
you tomorrow president Trump's supposed
to give a big speech tonight in Arizona
a lot of stuff happening tonight
actually president Trump
it's supposed to give a speech about his
new Afghanistan policy we'll talk about
that Plus president Trump is supposed to
do a rally in Arizona some violence
outside is expected so I'm sure that
things will get more heated not less
we'll talk about all of it I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]